your very first audition the beginning
oh god yes
just push play you ready little Brian
good luck I think I was like praying
like don't mess this up
America's Got Talent was really the
beginning of me finding my voice
I want it so bad it would mean so much
to me to win I thought you were
absolutely fantastic
not what I was expecting it's kind of
incredible did this let here
[Music]
it's crazy to think that four years ago
I just started ventriloquism you just
changed your life tonight
and now I'm competing to be the world
champion and I have a chance to
I said to the brisket on stage with wash
time well that was the beginning of the
rest of my life really
I do believe burritos I would love to
one I understand okay
which means I'm unemployed and I do
stand-up on the side I finally got the
opportunity to do stand-up I wanted so
much I wanted I really do
your grace go talent was my first stage
to win America's Gotanda champers it
will be a huge dream come true we love
the doll we do this is our lives we can
never thought we will be here and how
[Music]
there's more than even you know I think
you're capable of
[Music]
this was a moment that my life changed
because you know I became a contestant
on the show I thought I could just be
amazing to win and what do you do I am a
card magician and I was actually so
nervous during the act for the very
first time I'm really glad that I
decided to just believe in myself
and I'm so close to actually being
crowned champion I think now I really
want to do it it's not just a dream
anymore I'm living my dream to do what I
love this is a dream come true and I
don't want it end here so look there's a
3-2 win this competition it changes
everything because you're not just the
winner of America's Got Talent
you're the winner of America's Got
Talent the champions that tops
everything I've ever experienced in this
world
[Music]